good morning believe nation today's
message is over to you Serena Williams I
always believe I can win I never go into
a tournament saying I'm gonna lose you
know I just think first of all that's
bad thinking and I'm just thinking oh I
never I never said oh I could hope to do
this or hope to you know beat her always
going to a tournament thinking I have a
chance to win or else I'm not gonna play
so what do you think I love Serena
Williams and I always followed her on
how inspiring she was and I definitely
could connect on the subject always
believing that you can you win recently
I started training to be an instructor
in CVS and I personally didn't think I
can do it you know I always doubt myself
but I still do it anyway and first
couple of times when I came out and I
was being trained to be instructor in
front of students I always was scared at
the beginning I'm gonna fail I'm gonna
be so not funny they're not gonna
understand what I'm saying you know like
I always started with doubting myself
and the truth is that as soon as you
start doubting yourself you become more
nervous you know you're hesitating too
much lately when I come to the class I
have such a excited like I'm excited
myself and when I go out there I believe
that at the end of the day I'm gonna
have students who are gonna leave
without learning something and having
fun in the class so as soon as I started
changing my thinking that hey I'm not
gonna go out there and fail things
changed a little for me I'm starting to
see a difference and even if there's
something that I don't know yet and I'm
you know I haven't been teaching for a
long time when I'm positive everyone I
know that it's gonna go well when I know
at the end of the day winning means that
I'm gonna have customers were happy and
living in the class happily it works I
read this book called the power of
subconscious mind and I since I read
that book I always believe that there's
always true
in living that you can win there's
always gonna be failures there's always
gonna be mistakes that people make but
at the end of the day if you make
yourself believe that you're gonna be
successful there's a higher chance III
really believe there's a higher chance
that you're gonna succeed I love it I
think there's a funny thing in life
where you you get what you believe that
you can get you know you see people who
win the lottery and the next year
they're back to their level of whatever
income they had they've blown all the
money and if you take money away from
someone who's been super successful they
can usually get back to that level
really quickly they have standards right
they believe in themselves they don't
accept what's around them right now
right if I if I think I should be here
and I really believe it to my core and
I'm playing down here I know I'm gonna
get there where if I believe I'm down
here and this is where my my beliefs are
then I'm likely not gonna get to that
next level you know for me I look at
this business right
TDS Toronto dance salsa and I already
see a business as three times the size
of what we're at currently right now I
believe it's gonna happen we're gonna
make our way to get to that point you
know I've done it in another business
before and so it's my mindset right it's
gonna happen and so that's the approach
that I take going into every meeting we
have every class we have every business
decision that we have and so that's
gonna lead to the path of us actually
achieving that goal where my mindset was
you know whatever revenue are right now
that's that's as good as we're gonna be
then that's where we're going to stay
forever and so changing the beliefs so
that you actually think that you can
accomplish more than what you're getting
now is the game because when you figure
that out and you quickly rise up to
match those beliefs so the question the
day today is when you never achieve
something how do you believe that you
actually gonna do that getting deep on
the questions today got hit with a bow
and arrow that's what happens you do
films with a six year old in the studio
leave your answers in the in the
comments below we're gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another